>> Role models are very important almost in
any culture with respect to young people.
>> The first quality is the person must be
attractive. An attractive person gains a lot
of attention and that is what is required
of a role model.
>> The best thing I like it in my role model
it's he's human more than anything else. He
made a mistake and he can share his mistake
and his life with me.
>> The second quality is the person needs
to be charismatic.
>> There's a desperate need for role models
who will lead the region to the path of success
and will inspire people living in it.
>> Third quality, which is the role model,
needs to be representing the group and not
representing themselves.
>> We need a leader, of role models of our
own, of our generation. So I think by having
such a role model it will bring a big revolution
in the sense that it will give, bring us,
a lot of talent to improve the Middle East.
>> The last and final quality which is dedication
perseverance.
>> Strong morals and good character. The desire
and determination for global peace and equality.
And environmental and economical awareness.
>> So what we want to do is essentially create
role models that youth, to show even at a
young age can achieve. Raising the bar because,
so the Middle East can be in the global picture
of accomplishments and achievements.